To make the notation actually come
out relatively cleanly [LAUGH],
to minimize the number of subscripts
that I am going to mess up, we're
going to introduce a notation called
operator notation, functional notation.
And we're going to introduce
a particular, a Bellman operator.
So Bellman operator is
going to be a mapping,
a transformation,
from value functions to value functions.
You give me a Q function, the Bellman
operator will give you back, possibly,
a different Q function.
>> Okay.
>> So
it's a function from Q
functions to Q functions.
>> Does this operator have to have any
particularly interesting properties?
>> We're going to prove that
it has some properties, but
first let's define what it is.
>> Okay.
>> Boom!
>> Oh, okay.
>> So here's how we're going to
define this Bellman operator B.
We're going to give it a Q function,
and the new thing that we get out,
this B applied to Q, has the property
that at state action pair (S,a).
It's equal to the immediate reward
plus the discounted expected value of
the next state, where we look up the
value of the next state using whichever
Q function we were given
as input to the operator.
So, Q goes in, BQ comes out.
BQ is a new value function,
a new Q function.
Do you think you get that?
>> I think I do.
I guess, I don't know why
we're going through this yet.
>> Oh, I'm going to tell
you that quite yet, but
I just want to make sure that
you get it by quizzing you.
>> No!